de selenski ha dado a entender en sus
declaraciones que podría producirse un
renovado ataque sobre la capital kiev
precisamente porque este 24 de agosto se
celebran poco más de 30 años de la
independencia de la unión soviética el
ataque es factible
buenas noches creo que sí creo que es
una posibilidad muy concreta que haya
nuevos ataques sobre la capital
ucraniana no ataques demasiado potentes
porque yo creo que rusia nunca aspiro a
tomar la capital kiev sino que
simplemente le interesaba el sur y el
este de ucrania la costa del mar de azov
y la costa del mar negro la ciudad de
odessa nunca pensé que rusia aspirar a
tomar la capital pero puede haber
ataques de todas formas me parece
importante recordar que el 9 de mayo el
día de la victoria que tanto se celebra
en rusia también se ha visto se se
esperaban ataques más importantes y sin
embargo no ocurrió yo creo que puede
haber algún tipo de ataque probablemente
nada fuera de lo normal
en este contexto
bueno y la siguiente pregunta en qué
estado llegan ucrania y rusia a estos
seis meses de la guerra
en primer lugar hay que decir que según
la oficina del alto comisionado de los
derechos humanos de las naciones unidas
hay 5000 más de 5500 civiles muertos que
es el punto de partida para analizar
cualquier cosa de esta guerra más de
5500 civiles muertos rusia llega con
cierto desgaste después de estos seis
meses cada vez le cuesta más avanzar
tanto en el sur como en el este en la
zona del donbass está avanzando muy poco
en las últimas semanas y ucrania está
recuperando algunos territorios tales
que dijo en su momento que para
septiembre planeaba tener la ciudad de
gerzón de vuelta bajo control ucraniano
cosa que hasta ahora no ha ocurrido pero
hay ciertos avances de ucrania a partir
de la llegada de los lanzamisiles y mars
de parte de eeuu ucrania se va
fortaleciendo y rusia logra avances pero
cada vez menores y cada vez más lentos
bien y finalmente le quiero preguntar
cómo atraviesa el atentado contra la
rusa de área divina este aniversario en
su opinión no puede convertirse en un
motivo para
ser la ofensiva del kremlin sí
absolutamente puede ser un motivo puede
ser una excusa
de hecho el fcb el servicio de seguridad
ruso acusó a ucrania
según personas muy relevantes cercanas
al kremlin como por ejemplo margarita
simonián es responsabilidad del estado
ucraniano el atentado contra la tarea
divina y corresponden represalias contra
infraestructuras del estado ucraniano
infraestructura gubernamental de khyber
y ella por supuesto no tiene poder de
decisión sobre el kremlin y sobre su
accionar militar pero es una persona muy
relevante dentro de la narrativa de
rusia sobre todo de la narrativa hacia
el exterior de rusia entonces creo que
hay que tenerlo en cuenta si para el
estado ruso
quienes cometieron este atentado son
ucranianos que están avalados por el
estado ucraniano es muy posible que la
opción de excusa para nuevos ataques de
todas formas también creo que estos
nuevos ataques se darían de todas formas
aún sin el atentado digamos que no
cambia demasiado este atentado la guerra
va a seguir los ataques van a seguir
rusia nunca se ha replegado hasta ahora
con lo cual creo que el atentado no
cambia demasiado el accionar ruso por
más de que pueda llegar a usarse como
una excusa